we had the deepest conversations
ever it's just a lot the grossest
group date ever
and the most heartbreaking rose ceremony
ever
you're an amazing woman this is your the
bachelorette season 16
episode 7 recap grab your glasses
it's time for roses and roses
hi everybody i'm lauren zema
and we have gone
[Music]
we're deep
we're deep oh what did we think of this
episode of the bachelorette you guys
these conversations like i understand
and i don't pass judgment on anybody's
right these connections there's real
feelings and there's real
chemistry these kisses yes very deep
kissing
and and
and there was one
deep goodbye that we're gonna get into
and in order to get through i'm gonna
need to go
deep on this glass
[Music]
i think it has to be done
it had been a while i missed that song
anyway yes
this might have been one of the most
emotional episodes of the bachelorette
of all time so much to get to so let's
get to it so we're starting off light
the guys are gathered
joe's man bun is here and i love to see
it
by the way we've got our own j jc who
has a man bun of his
own and it is something to see show it
off jc
dan don't drink for all the man buzz
they're great
now you'll notice that i'm rhyming so
much because
the first group date was a song date
you are going to write an original
love song oh lord yes the guys had to
write a song for tasha and then you're
going to get the opportunity to perform
that love song
deportation and none of them did a very
good job
but we don't want them to feel alone we
want them to feel supported
so jc chrisann and i are going to make
up a song
about the songs they made up
[Music]
zack is on the bongos i think first met
you
in later and kenny manages
bands but he stinks awkward
blake had a ukulele
and when it came to instruments riley
had none to the magic that happened
then it was rapping you don't need no
harvard to agree
ivan was sweet she was looking like an
angel
my jaw dropped to the floor and demar
went acoustic
she stole my breath i liked his beat
[Music]
[Applause]
mocha
so babes that was our quick recap of the
bachelorette songs because it wasn't
worth talking about them for very long
and
anyway ivan got the rose ivan
your song really spoke to my heart who
did you think sounded the worst though
let me know in the comments below i'm
not trying to be shady i mean they
weren't trying very hard
you put the tea in my heart so
ivan's prize is a one-on-one with tasha
and
we are getting creative with these
one-on-ones aren't we
or are we okay but one more thing yeah
the floor is lava
so you're gonna have to get up on the
full count yeah no the floor is lava
so they're doing the flores lava
it's a game where you can't touch the
floor and so they're like isn't this
romantic this is gonna make a whole path
so we'll go here okay oh here i'm
throwing a pillow down that kind of
feels like cheating if i'm being honest
that was good now i'm on the pillow but
i put it there so i don't know why
this is an impressive game another
pillow throw it over there ivan yes
so funny we're not touching the floor
just the things that we put down where
we want to step
so not the best gameplay i've ever seen
we made it oh and anyway let me hit you
with a pillow that's romantic
oh my god and don't drink for every
feather
and so okay we're back here
and we're in love
gotta put this back now it felt like a
very
quarantined date to me right wait don't
push me
remember they're quarantining at la
quinta la corantina
and they only have so much so they're
doing what we were all doing
playing games drinking wine ordering in
and speaking of what in the home alone
two
was that ice cream sundae two scoops sir
two make it three i'm not driving but
all that
shallow silliness aside now we are
going in deep
i've been trying so hard my whole life
to like blend in because
i knew i was different tasia and ivan
are having this conversation that is so
emotional so open they share so much
i was in tears ivan is telling tasha
about his brother who went to prison
if i never had him like i never would
have been so open to like
you know people going through things
like drugs or alcohol and then the two
of them talk about
the true and real issues going on in our
country
hearing people yell like black lives
matter is just like
it hit me more than i realized and i
loved the show
for showing and sharing this
conversation as much as the bachelorette
is a silly little escape you know
sometimes we tackle the real issues
and i raise my glass do it what did you
guys think of it i mean then tasha was
crying
like it hurt a lot and ivan was gently
brushing the tears from her face
and i'm falling in deep and thinking am
i now
in love with ivan you guys i'm falling
hard and deep and fast for a different
guy every week on this season
and i just also kept thinking about what
a beautiful conversation this truly was
like when you think back to peter
webber's season
shut up peter you know i love him but
the
interactions that peter was having with
those women were
not on this level so much trauma all the
time there's so much good listening
happening here
i love that we have something that's
something i've never experienced before
so much mature responding discussion of
critical issues especially with like
george floyd
um and that's like police brutality and
that's something that like really hit
home for me
i've truly never felt this more when
i've said it
give ivan that rose and he got the rose
i don't want to accept this rose i will
100 accept that
but the question is how much is tasha
really falling for him
don't drink for every nice adjective she
used about ivan i've never met a guy
that's
so giving and thoughtful yet real and
honest
and like charismatic and she said that
he
understands her more than anyone else
can
and he understands me more than like i
don't think anybody
anybody else can what do you guys think
do you think there's an attraction there
or will this morph into a friendship
because sometimes the people we have the
most in common with become our best
friends
and i don't know about the chemistry
between tasha and ivan
quite yet but from
deep to dirty now we're on a group date
date card
said how far will you go for love and
you guys
you guys you guys
was this the grossest group date
ever you ready for me
we're gonna get into it but first we
have to bring some alumni here because
they're the only people willing to
quarantine for this season
i decided to bring two of my best
friends to help out with the date
becca kufrin and sydney yes and they
introduced the group date
the men are going to be playing truth or
dare we are going to be playing
tasha's truth or dare so the first gross
thing they all had to drink
horrifying smoothies don't drink for
every literally
gut-wrenching ingredient cow intestines
and
water scorpion chicken feet larva
and crickets buffalo testicles and
beetles
do you believe those things were in
those smoothies i'm not sure i do i
don't know how they would obtain
some of those items would you drink
those things
let me know in the comments below i'll
try a lot but but
not lava draw the line at larvae
yeah i wonder if he's gonna vomit
and cheers to the next gross thing which
wasn't gross for the guys but was gross
for
chris harrison
yes i framed this photo of him because
he's been gone so long
and i am so alone
[Music]
yes the second challenge in the dare
portion of this date was that the guys
had to ask
chris harrison to sign their buttocks
i'm gonna need a signature yeah it
doesn't shine a nice dark place
you know a little nasty but i thought it
was fun and chris was over there
living my dream date out having some
champagne
and a beautiful seafood by the water
yes please i miss them so much
[Music]
whatever you guys need for love man oh
and then here we go
oh it's weird that i made that noise as
i introduced this
everybody the third task
was that the men had to act out
on orgasm
[Music]
what did you guys think of this date the
men
had to pick up a speakerphone and blast
their orgasm impressions to the entire
property
you ready for me
we're just gonna go over some of the
highlights or incredibly deep dark low
lights whatever you want to call them
kenny shouted t
like for tasha and why did he say
back up what back up back up wait what
he said back up i don't know what that
means why does he appear to be in pain
i think you're good i think you're good
oh and then blake blake is acting it out
yes blake is banging on the podium and
doing movements
blake this is catchphrase not charades
blake is asking if she's ready for him
are you ready for me
i want to die oh ah oh
ah don't worry about that bennett said
don't worry about that
i worry ah
oh you guys i wanna die
which orgasm was the worst to listen to
let me know in the comments below
bro blake got some demon stuff
blake need to go to church god dawg
again i ask you was this the grossest
group date ever embrace it baby embrace
it
but that was only the dare part now we
gotta do the truth
tonight is the truth part of the truth
or dare challenge
and this is where we are getting deep
even our boy our being yay
our harvard hey bennett
gets serious you guys he had to propose
earlier to tasha on a part of the date
that i didn't even talk about which is
when they were eating a hot pepper and
trying not to puke while proposing
and he is using that experience earlier
to open up about himself he explains
that he almost
got married wow i was engaged i was
fully engaged and dialed up for a
wedding
but as much as i was watching this i was
also looking at tasha and
tasha's eyes what did you think of her
expression i just
felt she wasn't that into bennett it was
a reality check you know
you guys the truths portion of the date
really did get me
don't drink for every deep talk we had i
never thought this was gonna happen
and i'm so excited for it here because i
want to get life started family is the
most important thing to me
my worst fear is getting divorced and
part of the problem is tasia's so
amazing i mean how could they not all
fall in love with her
will these be the most genuinely deep
relationships
ever
okay okay
this 1912 librarian caller's really
holding my head up
i'm using this outfit let me know in the
comments below
my aesthetic of this year is adult
american girl doll and i feel that i'm
living that right now
i was a samantha that's my deep truth
these relationships truly have potential
sleep well
i'm excited about every single one of
them i have spoken before about how i
felt tasha was playing some games
i think some of the roses she's given
out in past episodes have been to guys
she's been attracted to
but not necessarily truly madly deeply
into
but now it's getting real i'm at a place
now where i'm like really looking at
this and wanting this
and craving this and like wanting to
build something with someone
speaking of looks she and zach have this
talk where she is
staring at him very differently than the
way she was
gazing at bennett am i right and zach
gets the rose
i'd love to know if you would accept
this rose absolutely
who do you think tasha had the most
tangible connection with on this date
let me know in the comments below
i'm gonna walk to her room secret
mission style in the cover of darkness
so we love when somebody sneaks out to
see the lead it usually happens about
once a season
and i do mean once a season but this is
a season of twos
so we're gonna get two men doing a sneak
and see
like consistency for a baby but this is
an adult interaction with a woman
i'm going to go over to tasha's and just
you know let her know how excited i am
to see her
yes here we go tasha is hanging out in
her room with water and wine we love to
see it and now it's not someone but some
two who are going to see her and that
duo is
ben and ed yes is this a franchise first
that two guys try to see our leading
lady on the same night
bachelor historians let me know in the
comments below they're even kind of
wearing
the same shirt and have you guys noticed
that
the men are sort of all dressed alike
this season it made me wonder if they
brought
not the right clothes for this level of
heat in the desert and production had to
go out and
buy them some new stuff let me know in
the comments below but you know we could
tell
someone was going to triumph here and i
thought maybe it would be when they both
arrived in tasha's room but uh no no no
uh
soon soon soon er and got lost
yes i loved this ed looked like he was
getting a little confused in the
darkness of the desert
and he wound up at chris harrison's room
[Music]
chris ted how's it going
it's 2 30 in the morning what are you
doing please come home
[Music]
you know should i be getting jealous i
mean chris harrison is
signing butts and welcoming men into his
room for
wine come on in dude you want drink
oh sure wow let me know in the comments
below cheers no no cheers cheers to
coming by oh but from one dynamic duo to
another
we are getting our moment with ben
and tasha and i just love the connection
between these two i
really feel the chemistry well i
will forgive you what you will they're
just both so beautiful and i just feel
them popping through the screen
until they used a certain
phrase one that sends me off the deep
end
deja says ben's gotta
show up if you want to be here and like
you want to continue doing this like i
need you to show up
can we just please of course that's the
phrase that claire used about a million
and 12 times with dale
all i've ever wanted is amanda show up
for me and i'm just wondering if we can
please never use that phrase again
just show up but they're gonna keep
saying it
so don't drink every time they say it
i need you to show up if you think i
need you to show up i'm here right now i
showed up right now
cheers to um being a show up guy
my name's ben this is me showing up she
said i need you to show up
and so i'm just going to keep showing up
i really want to show up for you
but anyway these people are too stunning
for me
to just write off like that so back to
basha
ben says he is sorry for letting tasha
down i just wanted to apologize
for making you disappointed in me and i
do find quick forgiveness because i'm
swept up in the cinema
of all this splendor i mean they're just
two good-looking people you know and i
like to watch it it's a reality show
what can we say
yes good-looking muscular bend with that
hair
ben aka captain america is staring into
tasha's eyes
and tasha aka wonder woman is looking
back into his
and then he goes in for that kiss and
ben are
you kidding me what ben does really well
in a kiss is he grabs the face and you
know
we really like that we do do you like a
face grab during a kiss
it's nice let me know in the comments
below as i think about it
because we do have such a super cast are
these all
super heroes i've already called
bennett's superman
then is captain america tasha is wonder
woman
is that ant-man is our intellect ivan
spider-man are they the avengers come to
save the season
you're joking oh boy oh and then there's
a knock at the door and
is it ed aka the hulk now might be a
really good time for you to get angry
that's my secret captain
i'm always angry
oh no it's not it's more champagne great
so much champagne tonight so much to
celebrate
[Music]
now it's the rose ceremony and i'm
scared
and i'm sad because i gotta talk about
something so bad
let's get to it first kenny says what
we're all thinking we got to know the
guys and now things are more serious it
seems like she's getting a little more
serious now and oh yes very serious
tasha's basically in a wedding
dress hi guys we're having the cocktail
party first and that means tasha is
going to talk to the guys and then grab
station first
sure but he doesn't want to do any
talking ben goes in for another kiss
gosh he knows how to grab a face
[Music]
oh and now we are with noah and he talks
about how the guys have been giving him
a bit of a hard time
he says when i hopped the fence i knew i
would get
a lot of heat and when i hopped the
fence yeah i
knew i would be getting a lot of heat
dan
noah we've heard that before he just
jumped the fence yes noah tells stacia
that apparently since he got the rose on
that group wrestling date
the men have said that she gave him that
rose just to rile things up
for the show she's just doing that kind
of for a show
to get us going things like that you're
joking no i'm not joking
but keisha is annoyed at her integrity
being questioned no one's ever
questioned my integrity or my character
ever
now i'm actually pissed off and and i
understood that she says that she would
not just give someone a rose
for the show i'm not gonna give you rose
for show i do believe that
she says i am a grown woman and i can
make decisions on what i want to do and
if you're going to be questioning me
i'll walk you outside
i'm a grown woman and i can make
decisions based off of what i want to do
and if you're going to be questioning me
like i'll gladly walk you outside
and i did have a bit of an issue with
that because i think
especially as you're first exploring a
relationship you're allowed to question
another person you know tasha these guys
can challenge you
a bit too and she cancels the rest of
the cocktail party
i'll see you guys at the wrist ceremony
did you think that was fair of wonder
woman let me know in the comments below
what did i just shed some light on i
missed something now the guys are
confused but noah owns that he talked to
tasha i mean i
talked to her and said that some of the
guys think you gave me the rose just
just for show and don't drink for every
time he was
verbally annihilated by the men who are
older than him
if there was an issue with anybody say
it here bro i will talk on you all day
easy with talking to you all day if you
have a problem with me come come see me
bro
you ruined everyone's night here you can
you imagine having an argument with a 14
year old
that's how i feel right now exactly it
sounds a little bad for noah i'll be
honest
what did you think let me know in the
comments below okay and it was pretty
funny when jason said noah
is very high school i think he's just
very
very high school i said lol
jason so there was no time to talk we
had no additional moments to go
deeptasia took that away from us and it
is
time for the rose ceremony which zach
says
is gonna be a massacre
the road ceremony tonight is going to be
a massacre
oh i'm scared now oh i know these guys
and i care now
although oh who is that is that oh
that's spencer we've not seen spencer in
a minute oh hi spencer you're still here
ben tasia is giving out the roses
and here's who goes is
and the goodbyes are feeling real
and then this rose ceremony becomes a
massacre
joe is gone
you're an amazing woman you've got
awesome guys there so
you can't go wrong thanks joe joe the
anesthesiologist
put me under oh i need a drink
what did you babes think of joe
being no mo i couldn't believe it i felt
just last week i'd gotten so invested in
joe i was rooting for joe i couldn't
believe it you know
i was all-conference in volleyball in
high school
an amazing woman i'm a lover i'm not a
fighter i'm gonna say it this was the
most
painful rose ceremony elimination
i've ever felt and here's why to me it
was the loss of potential
of what could have been but what we
never knew it's different when someone's
sent home when you know the person has
such stronger feelings for others but at
this stage in the game
to say goodbye to this guy to send the
man bun
into the setting son
hi babes it's me coming at you with a
quick and barely conscious vlog hence
the glasses and the fact that i'm
literally horizontal but
had to weigh in on a few things one matt
james's
bachelor season promo we've seen several
trailers now including a new one on this
episode of the bachelorette what did you
guys think
i really love that we're getting fall
cozy vibes him in a turtleneck
very interesting that he's never been in
love what will that mean let me know in
the comments below but i am so excited
and then speaking of great guys oh babes
i interviewed joe yes
when he was made no mo i couldn't just
let him out of our lives forever
that interview is up at etonline.com
shameless plug i gotta go to sleep i
love you so much bye
oh but that is the episode everybody we
have to process the losses
we have to dive deep and then pull
ourselves back
up and i love you guys so much thank you
as always for watching with me i am
available to you
on instagram tick tock and twitter at
laurenzema or if you want a personal
message from me i am on cameo
oh and you know i just realized it's
about to be thanksgiving
and i'm dressed like a pilgrim
anyway i hope that everybody enjoys
their time i love you all so much
be like tasha and ivan and eat
everything in sight
and i will see you next week all my love
i'm off the deep end watch as i
definite i'll never leave the ground